so tribes what do they matter why do
they matter I mean where can we start
with this why do tribes matter for men
you know I think a lot of guys find it
pretty lonely out there when it comes to
uh navigating the world finding uh
people that get it you know they they
just they just get it they just fall
they just fall in line and don't
they're not drunk on the Kool-Aid if I
can put it that way you know what I mean
there's a lot of plugged in beta males
out there that think that's just going
along with the program to get along is
the way to go and I think at some point
most guys discover
when chaos ensues that that doesn't work
doesn't serve them doesn't serve them in
work and creation of wealth networking
with women any of those things it just
doesn't work
so
tonight we're going to be talking about
men and masculinity and tribes gangs
whatever you want to call it I've been
an avid follower of
Hollywood films that placate the The
Narrative or the notion of
gang type of activity uh Mob type of
activity in fact while I was on the
flight to and from Florida I was
listening to uh Michael franzisi or
franchisee I don't know if I'm
pronouncing his last name right but he's
uh interesting guy I've watched some
podcast interviews with him and uh he
put a book out called I'll make an offer
you can't refuse
and he's kind of highlighting uh what it
was like being in the Italian mafia
ranks
um
code
why certain things are written why other
things weren't written how and why guys
would get whacked all of this stuff
um
so to say that I have an interest in it
is an understatement
um
back in the day when I was a 20
something year old and I talked about it
and
my book The unplugged Alpha if you
haven't read it get it it's on Amazon
there's a second revision coming out
very soon I'll talk about that in a bit
but I talk about in the book a chapter
on why it's important for a guy to own a
motorcycle
so I think I'll start there because
childhood tribes that I've had were
different I mean you can't call Boy
Scouts a tribe you know it just it's
just not it's kind of the foundation
it's kind of the precursor you know to
males getting together doing things that
include activities
with tasks at hand basic stuff putting
up a tent collecting firewood striking
matches getting a fire going basic stuff
right but I think I really observed it
coming into its own
when I got on a motorcycle
I'll tell you why
because
as much fun as driving cars and exotic
cars and doing these road trips that I
often do that I've talked about is
there's a different kind of camaraderie
that you get on a motorcycle
it's very difficult to explain but it
exists and it's like taking a frying pan
to the forehead it's something that I
still to this day look back fondly on I
haven't owned a motorcycle in a long
time couple decades now whenever a
friend of mine comes out and has one
he sees me looking at it he goes take it
out for a rep and I do and
it brings me back to my 20s we spent
all of that time in coffee shops into
the wee hours of the night talking
hanging out amongst other men on
motorcycles doing tasks
not just sitting there talking and
drinking coffee or anything like that
but but actually going out and
Performing tasks riding ramps we would
do all kinds of
I mean can I say Insidious things maybe
maybe the law didn't like what we were
doing let's just put it that way
but we did them and we did them as a
group of men traveling in groups
um groups as small as three or four
sometimes as large as 50 depending on
what we were doing and this is the first
immersion that I got into the notion
that the way of men is the way of the
gang the way of men is a way of the
tribe there's a book uh Jack Donovan
wrote I have it here on my desk it's
called the way of men summarizes it is
the way of men is the way the gang it's
a book about masculinity it's a book
about the tribal nature of men it's a
book about
why men need to test each other and hold
each other accountable and do things
together I think if you go back I mean
if we could go back in a time machine
000 500 000 years
you know back to the hunter-gatherer
times where
you'd be out hunting and or gathering uh
for sustenance you weren't sitting
across from each other talking we didn't
have screens and cameras and this sort
of stuff you'd be sitting shoulder to
shoulder probably stalking an animal
whispering in a low breath about the
kill lining up for it maybe even you
know what it was that you were going to
do that night and who you were going to
sleep with who knows
but the reality is is that we've
operated this way
for eternity
um we're definitely social
we definitely like the social aspect of
life I think women for the most part
tend to be better at this especially as
guys get older as guys get older we suck
at this stuff we'll let friends go way
of the Wayside we'll let women remove
um
our tribes from us if you're a guy that
was into playing hockey uh pick up
hockey or
um you know ball teams all kinds of
stuff you know I see guys do this all
the time and oh you don't have time for
that anymore we have a household to run
we have this to do we have that too and
guys will abandon their friendships and
their tribes that they have you know to
placate
her whims and desires the notion of
betaization through a thousand
concession is inclusive in how men walk
away from uh male tribes and masculinity
all right let me get into these notes
over here
um
so talk about the notion
of realizing the reality of tribes when
I was a lot younger motorcycles was
basically where it started off for me
man it's just real
it's real
um so let's talk about where you're not
going to find good men that are good at
being men I think again I go back to
Donovan's you know definition because
everything that I've seen out there
when people start diving down these
rabbit's holes and talking about
masculinity in tribes and men and all
that sort of stuff most of them get
incredibly wrong okay
come on YouTube cooperate there we go
so you're not going to find these guys
in places where you have
no barrier to entry if you don't have a
barrier to entry
for example pickup hockey
if you have hockey equipment are you
good on skates does somebody know you
can they vouch for you have they seen
you skate you know do they think that
you have the capacity to be useful on
the ice to the team right like you just
can't show up at any kind of hockey
arena with some equipment and say hey
guys I like to come and play with you
mind if I join in unlikely to happen
that's not how it works you have to have
well organized
some sort of
barrier to entry doesn't matter if it's
a some kind of firewall paywall whatever
it happens to be a test
and you know joining like a private
Facebook group where it's like why do
you want to join this group
do you have right you know this is the
standard basic [__] this is the basic
[__] realm of most men's tribes out
there and they suck going into free
groups
um I'm a member of a lot of free groups
on uh I'm gonna call them Facebook
groups on social media
where
councils of iron strong men men
masculinity you name it whatever name it
is that they've slapped together words
of iron masculinity and steel and all
that sort of stuff
um virtue order you know whatever it
happens to be most of them suck okay
um I get a lot of my material from the
stuff that the algorithms pick up and
show me in my feed uh I don't engage or
comment on the stuff because it's like
talking to somebody that doesn't want to
hear a story but what ends up happening
is it sends the algorithms which I find
useful send me anything that's trending
and it's always the same stuff there's
always some dorks that are like my wife
doesn't want to sleep with me I've been
changing the baby's diapers cutting the
grass I just put the winter tires on her
car for and she won't even touch me you
know we haven't touched each other in
three four six weeks do you get these
nerds in the comments going well have
you looked at her love language what's
her love language have you tried that
yet you know like the standard just
garbage that doesn't work these this is
why you get these types of results from
these types of groups they're plugged in
beta males they're basically build a
beta build a better beta groups is what
they are okay these guys sleep walk
through life they think that if you just
pray the right woman will come along
they think that if the right woman comes
along the Unicorn you know comes along
and they just do the right thing right
we talked about this before they tell
men you do what's right they tell women
do what's right for you girl and these
guys think if they just do the right
thing everything will be hunky-dory
tickety-boo done everything's fine most
of these groups are tribes of betas
building better betas and while there
might be some improvement in some growth
in there you're not going to get exactly
you know what you want in it
yeah thanks moff for clarification we're
talking about Jack Donovan to be very
clear
um
if you want to hop in as well you know
when you get a moment I'll I'll bring
you in first so we can sort of talk a
little bit about the um weekend as well
when I get to that
um
the other thing that you've got to
recognize with groups of men tribes
gangs whatever it is you want to call it
whatever it is we're going to call it on
this cast
um women talk men do
if you're in a room in a space where all
it is is just yap yap yap yap yap
post post yap yap yap funny mean hahaha
like Emoji yap yap yap yap yap you're
masturbating that's all it is I'm just
gonna be honest with you you're not
getting
what a group of men need to put in and
to get out of the environment from each
other just be very clear about that men
do things women talk that's why when
women get together let's go have dinner
girls they put on their outfits they do
their hair and all sorts of stuff and
they sit around and they're talking
they're talking about pecky from the HR
department and what she's been doing
they talk about some part-timer that
works in another business they talk
about husbands they talk about
boyfriends they talk they talk about
celebrities they talk okay they don't
generally do things men on the other
hand it is as a prerequisite of a tribe
to work of a gang to be useful does
things you can take the Italian mafia
the mob you know as an example they
don't sit around and do nothing they're
very Machiavellian in the way that they
operate
um one of the things that kept coming up
over and over again in franchisee's book
was the notion of Machiavelli versus
Solomon King Solomon I've downloaded
Machiavelli's audiobook I think it's
called the prince so I want to see what
angles you know are talked about in
there but but the mob is very very
focused on doing [__] more or less the
accumulation of influence power and more
specifically wealth right they don't
just sit around and talk about stupid
[__] who's banging who Becky from HR or
any of that nonsense they're doing
something productive right and this is
one of the things that I think a lot of
guys miss when it comes to tribes
and gangs and stuff like that is they're
not necessarily doing something
productive
just spinning their wheels okay they're
just doing nothing they're talking
is there advancement are there things
happening is there forward movement
going on
and most of them absolutely not
um
I could I can go into I mean
I'm not going to do it I'm not going to
do it but do yourself a favor you guys
go in to one of these private Facebook
groups and you'll see what I'm talking
about many of you watching right now are
probably watching
from that angle too and understand
exactly what I'm talking about let's
talk about tribes Within
networks so the manual swap is something
that I think many of you are already
familiar with also known as the
manosphere I call it the Mana swap
because of the type of men that are in
the space not good men nor are they good
at being men but they have little
categories of their own gangs and tribes
within the man of swamp the pickup
artist these guys are primarily focused
on getting girls cold approaching women
getting their numbers and generally
speaking getting a same night light
they're just looking there to rack up
notches pick up artists that sort of
thing men's rights activists same sort
of group right these guys just focus on
being activists for men's rights some of
them are men some of them are women but
they generally go around going wah it's
not fair on men and I completely agree
with all the observations but that's how
the world sees it they just go
and they're not particularly effective
I've said this many times for the type
for the type of activism that these
gangs of men the mras are about
the way to make it work is only going to
be if you get the gals together in the
thousands ideally tens or hundreds of
thousands marching on Capitol to change
laws that are hostile towards men but
they'll never do that they'll just talk
they'll just they'll just talk right
uh what else we got in that tribe we got
the mgtow guys the men going their own
way I have a chapter in my book about
that you should be very familiar with it
if you've read my book again if not get
your head around it understand it you
got the tradecon cruise right also in
the man of swamp these are the guys that
are just like wiper up put a ring on her
put some babies in her and just wipe her
up and just hope for the best they don't
say hope for the best they're basically
like you're not going to be a style like
those other guys but that's essentially
the strategy then you have all the
different pills black pill purple pill
white pill these are all collectives of
guys getting together doing something
now
as far as effectiveness
and as far as results go you're not
gonna you're not gonna see much in the
way of movement right I've said this
before you can't really trust guys that
are completely obsessed with getting
tail
right just rocking up not just chasing
women right and you also can't trust
guys that can't get tail
because both of them will throw you
under the bus
there's a weakness to both of them right
the men that I mean you know if you go
back to the Mob you know the Italian
mafia you know for example like the
French easy book there's almost no talk
in the entire book again the book's
title I'll make an offer you can't
refuse there's next to no talk
about women in that book
it's about
forming a Brotherhood accountability
navigating slippery slopes it's about
making money it's about dealing with
obstacles
it's about holding each other
accountable
but there's no talk in there about tail
the entire man of swamps about tail so
just Merit in on that a little bit right
think about that for a second I'm not
saying go out and join the mafia or
create your own Mafia but what I'm
saying is the effectiveness
and the depth in which these men go and
the Brotherhood that exists the code of
conduct if you will that exists again
you step out you don't toe the line you
break a rule you get whacked you pay the
ultimate Polaris right they just kill
you
right they make that decision on you so
contemplate those things right I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full-length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out